Khloe Kardashian poses topless while 8  months pregnant super cozy and you just  feel secure in your own body the 33 year  old reality star showed off her adorable  growing baby bump in nothing but a pair  of maternity jeans Khloe is expecting  her first child a baby girl with  boyfriend  Tristan Thompson very soon she launched  good mama on Wednesday a spinoff from  her successful denim line good American  for expectant mothers I think the  biggest misconception about maternity  wear is that you can't be stylish and  sexy while you're pregnant ET spoke with  Khloe in January where she gushed over  her pregnancy now that I'm showing more  I feel sexy I feel great and I feel so  lucky to feel so great